[Music]
[Music]
On June 30 and the final hours of the
Muslim holy month of Ramadan
government's forces stormed a peaceful
sit-in outside the military headquarters
in the Sudanese capital Khartoum I was
there in April and back then resolution
is in full swing months of nationwide
protests and helped topple the rule
dictator Amidala Bashir a transitional
military council made up mostly of his
allies took over from him but the
protesters weren't happy with that so
they occupied a vast area outside of the
generals as offices and refused to leave
until the civilian government was put in
place the sit-in was everything that al
Bashir Sudan wasn't unarmed inclusive
and free many told me they saw and the
sit-in a glimpse of what they wanted
their country to become violence from
the crackdown on the sit-in spread
across the capital tents were burned
dozens were killed and hundreds were
injured these four young protesters were
on the streets that day and lived to
tell what happened
as we were forced to leave the compound
of the city of witness that they were
about seven riot police officials that
were actually bludgeoning someone to
death who killed while they were dumping
of the barricade I I really don't know
what happened to them
people that wanted to retaliate by going
out again they would shoot at random
with people that they thought might be
building barrack barricades again
especially young men they killed our
really good friend mother and and and
and they took dead bodies in the Nile
eyewitnesses claimed both men and women
were raped in the dispersal others were
sexually harassed as they tried to flee
but it's unclear exactly how many people
were targeted dr. Salim a Sharif runs a
trauma center and says she's aware of at
least eight cases of rape the brutality
of the June 3rd crackdown marked a
turning point in Sudan's revolution it
showed the protesters that while they
may have hasta del Bashir the system he
left behind remains intact and ruthless
and one key element of that system is
willing to go to extremes to preserve
its power
it was the rapid support forces that
terrorized us we know it's his militia
the rapid support forces or RSF for
short is the paramilitary group believed
to have led the violence of June 3rd
they're led by this man John O Muhammad
Hamden simply known as committee many
consider him Sudan's de-facto leader he
was part of Sudan's old guard under al
Bashir years ago committee was recruited
to be a commander of the gender weed
militias which Human Rights Watch has
implicated in alleged war crimes and
crimes against humanity carried out in
Sudan's civil war in Darfur it be used
to murder loot and pillage villages in
western Sudan and in that school and we
never imagined that these things could
actually happen to us and perform but
they did happen
soldiers were raping women because again
this is what they've been trained to do
they've done this all of you know years
later and Beshear upgraded it into a
paramilitary group and renamed it the
rapid support forces he has used them
against Sudan's people ever since at the
height of the protests in April commit
the abandoned al-bashir
and initially since sympathetic to the
demonstrators but now he's accused of
spearheading the June 3rd crackdown even
though he has vowed to investigate what
the military council has called mistakes
committed during the dispersal
protesters say an investigation isn't
enough they need to be
government protesters have told me the
June 3rd is the moment that Hema T's
mask fell once and for all and that he
has no interest in sharing power with
civilians because a civilian government
could ultimately implicate him in
al-bashir crimes meanwhile the
repression against demonstrators
continues including a block on internet
access but protesters have Indiana
they're just changing how they organize
small protests reminiscent of the early
days of the revolution in December are
still popping up across the country and
Sudanese people around the world have
been organizing protests to bring
attention to their issue
people are still they still have that
fire they still you know they're still
fighting for freedom to see you
[Music]
nobody would go to snatch
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]